Here we see a cute young kid who’s drawn
himself a moustache with the help
of a sketchpen!
But apart from being cute, the image conveys
a lot!
Yes!
And
one such important message which we all relate
to is the goal of becoming an
adult!
Yes, as kids we all feel like growing up being
like the elders in our family.
However, little do we know what it actually
takes to reach that stage in life!
Is it difficult?
In this video and the upcoming ones we will
see what exactly
makes us grow from a small kid to an adult.
Let us get introduced to the
concept of ADOLESCENCE and PUBERTY in this
video.
Wait a second…is there a difference between
the two terms?
Of course yes!
Let us talk about Adolescence first.
The term Adolescence comes from the
Latin word Adolescere which literally means
to grow up.
So is adolescence the
activity of growing up?
Or is it the changes that occur in our body
when we
grow up?
Or is it simply the phase of growing up?
Well the term refers to the PHASE OF GROWTH.
Yes!
The TIME PERIOD in
which several changes occur in a kid’s body
that turns him or her into an adult,
is called Adolescence.
This time period is remarkably marked by not
only
physical, but also mental, emotional and psychological
changes in the person.
So if this is the meaning of Adolescence,
then what could PUBERTY mean?
Just
take a guess!
Let me help you with that.
If adolescence is the time period or
stage of development, then shouldn’t puberty
be the ACTUAL CHANGES?
Yes!
Puberty refers to the process of changes…
bodily changes to be precise.
Do we know the age group in which the era
of adolescence shines upon the
kid?
Yes!
Correctly guessed!
The age which ranges from around THIRTEEN
TO
NINETEEN YEARS is the time for adolescence.
And don’t we know a particular
name for this age group?
Of course!
It is called the TEEN AGE!
It’s the age
during which there are many transformations
happening in the individual.
In simple words can we say that adolescence
is more like a journey?
And then
what will puberty be?
Puberty can be thought of as the various junctions
where the train halts!
Each junction is different from the other
and has specific
variations.
Can you tell me where this journey takes us?
Yes!
The final
destination will be ADULTHOOD!
And how do we understand that the
destination of adulthood has reached?
The most important characteristic of
adulthood is REPRODUCTIVE MATURITY.
Yes!
The bodies of male as well as
female individuals become capable of reproduction.
However the journey is not extra ordinarily
fascinating as it seems, because
there are many problems faced on the way.
In a nutshell, Adolescence and
puberty change the individual in many ways.
To understand the changes that occur during
puberty do watch our next video!